this year's e3 was exciting for many
reasons
CD Projekt RED finally unveiled
cyberpunk the game we've waited years to
see in action intend to let Smash
Brothers ultimate loose which comes out
in just a few short months and will
launch with every playable character
from every previous smash game and not
one to disappoint but Fez de finally
confirmed two games that have only
existed as rumors until now the Elder
Scrolls 6 and star filled oh yeah and
they announced a little game called
fallout 76 but wait what about those
other big games we know are coming that
didn't appear at the show I'm sure
there's one or two you have in mind but
there were a surprising number of absent
E's and by golly we're gonna call them
out we're not mad or just disappointed
at the top of our list of the biggest
games missing from e3 2018 we have to
mention Red Dead Redemption 2 now
Rockstar Games isn't one to make a big
show of its wares at conventions but
with the long-awaited Red Dead sequel on
the horizon it was a bit surprising that
it didn't appear in either Sony or
Microsoft's press conference we already
know a bit about the games setting in
characters but assuming its scope is as
massive as we all believe it to be
surely there's something new Rockstar
could have shared to keep the hype train
a-rollin alas we'll have to wait a bit
longer it seems perhaps until the game
releases this October next on our list
is a big game from Nintendo that we know
practically nothing about metroid prime
4 was revealed at e3 2017 with a simple
logo and nothing else
intend no has been pretty quiet about
the game since then only revealing the
producer Ken cicada nabe and that he is
leading a new talented team on the
project that means the original Metroid
Prime team at retro studios is out of
the picture but who has taken their
place is anyone's guess Nintendo likely
didn't discuss Metroid Prime 4 as it
tends to focus on games coming out
within the current calendar year which
puts samus's next adventure further down
the line in 2019 or potentially 2020
Nintendo's not off the hook yet oh no
not even close the recent release of
Bayonetta 1 and 2 on switch proved that
people are still hungry for the
over-the-top offbeat series from
Platinum Games we know Bayonetta 3 is
coming thanks to the teaser trailer
Nintendo showed off at last year's Game
Awards but aside from small esoteric
hints buried within that video we're
left with more questions than answers
when will it come out
who
as with Metroid Nintendo is likely
staying quiet on the game because it's
still a ways off alright before we give
Nintendo a break it's worth reflecting
on all of the pokemon news that
announced just before e3 Pokemon let's
go Pikachu and Pokemon let's go Eevee
are two Pokemon games coming to switch
their integration with Pokemon go mobile
games sounds pretty nifty as is the
pokeball plus controller that players
can use to simulate catching Pokemon
people will no doubt eat up the ghost
which games but the series biggest fans
are only mildly satisfied by this news
where is the fresh info on the new main
line massive world shattering switch
Pokemon game that Nintendo announced
last year why wasn't it this year's e3
well that's a good question all we
learned in recent weeks is that the game
is coming out in the second half of 2019
there is no gameplay footage no
screenshots heck not even a title to
rattle around our brains for now whether
by accident or by design Nintendo once
again has our imaginations running wild
alright with Nintendo out of the way
I've got a bone to pick with Square Enix
that's right you the publisher who
proudly announced the remake of Final
Fantasy 7 years ago you the gatekeeper
to my nerdy hopes and dreams of one day
ascending the ranks of the chocobo
racing league in the golden saucer in
glorious 4k I know you've had some
difficulties working with outside
partners and I know this is a hugely
ambitious undertaking overshadowed by
unreasonable demands from fans like me
but come on and give me something to
work with a lot of people are beginning
to doubt this game will ever come out
and after final Oki sievert fifteens 10
year development cycle can you blame
them prove them wrong and give me a
reason to believe this will be great
maybe next year
alright let's take it down a notch at
the start of 2017 Square Enix and Marvel
announced a multi game project and
thanks to an eagle ID user near lac over
at neogaf it seems job listings suggest
the first game will be an online
third-person avengers game or at least a
third-person action game with an online
component it's hard to say too much with
any certainty right now but you'd think
Square Enix would have had something to
say at e3 18 months after the initial
announcement but you'd be wrong studio
Crystal Dynamics is definitely working
on the game and given the team's
incredible work reinventing lara croft
in recent years we can't wait to see
what they do with the avengers to help
them stand out from the influx of Marvel
Studios films
during that same press conference where
square Enix announced the Final Fantasy
7 remake we also learned the
long-awaited Shenmue 3 was also on the
way from Sega legend to you Suzuki the
bits and pieces of news that have
surfaced over the years have been a bit
underwhelming but the team's regular
Kickstarter updates have us feeling
hopeful that the game is getting the
attention it deserves regardless it was
yet another game missing from this
year's e3 much to the disappointment of
forklift fans everywhere yeah that's it
psycho nobs next on our list is
Psychonauts - Tim Schafer has had a long
and illustrious career in games with the
original Psychonauts being one of his
most lauded creations he was no surprise
then win Psychonauts to raise 3.8
million dollars in funding back in 2015
it was however a bit disappointing when
it was revealed in late 2017 that the
game would not hit its 2018 release
window that's okay games have delays so
they can be improved right still I would
be lying if I said I expected
Psychonauts to to skip out on e3 this
year though I still have faith in Tim
and everyone else at Double Fine
productions but their presence was
notably missed the last two games on our
list bio mutant and Darksiders 3 are
let's say partners in crime both games
are being published by THQ Nordic and
both have earned a lot of excitement
from the gaming audience since their
announcements last year it seemed only
natural that we find out more during a 3
right that is unless you are a die-hard
sock
football fan in this case THQ is
reasoning for skipping out on the show
is completely understandable the World
Cup in its own words it is with great
regret that we at THQ Nordic must report
that we will be unable to miss a single
moment of this great sporting event
therefore we will be forced to stay in
our lovely Viennese beer gardens
blowing the froth off a couple watching
football and one or two cool press
conferences on Twitch instead of rocking
it ourselves you know what Bravo THQ why
should as players be the only ones who
have fun assuming everything is on the
up-and-up for these various projects
will surely hear more about them in the
months to come with comic-con Gamescom
and various packs events on the horizon
so rather than be too sad about what
didn't make it to the show give a shout
out below to your favorite game that did
make an appearance at e3 and if you
missed out on all the great
announcements and shirt the weird ones -
head on over to gamespot.com slash III
to catch up on everything you missed
you